- We put our foot down and
insisted in being respected
even though we're prisoners.
She said who are you to ask for my name?
What's your name?
You have a limited time to stay
on Earth.
We do not care whether
the cat is black or white
as long as it can catch mice.
But humility is one of the
most important qualities
which you must have.
I was paralyzed because it made my day.
Our attitudes towards
any country is determined
by the attitude of that
country to our struggle.
But our brain said if you
don't talk with this man
your country will go up in flames.
It is the desire of every freedom fighter
to disappear under a cloud of glory.
I don't know if I have paralyzed you.
- [Ted] No, no, no, no, no, I.
(audience cheering loudly)
- He was a South African
anti-apartheid revolutionary,
politician, and philanthropist.
He served as President of
South Africa from 1994 to 1999.
In South Africa, he's often described
as the Father of the Nation.
He's Nelson Mandela and here are his
top 10 rules for success.
(quick sibilant music)
- How did you get the racist guards
to treat you with respect?
You were in prison and you
said I will only respond
to the name Mandela or Mr. Mandela.
- You must fight the battle for dignity.
- Um hmm.
- On the very first day you go to jail.
- [Oprah] Really?
- And that's what we did.
We put our foot down and
insisted in being respected
even though we're prisoners.
And we, thankfully, succeeded in that.
When I found
some place in my country
and a lady inside the telephone
I then asked, to whom am I speaking?
She said, you're speaking to me.
(audience laughing)
I said, well, lady, I
know I am speaking to you
but what's your name?
She said, who are you to ask for my name?
What's your name?
(audience laughing loudly)
I said, well, lady, as soon
as you tell me your name,
I'll tell you mine.
But as we argued as to who
should tell his or her name,
she became very cross.
And she said, you seem
to be a backward person.
Have you passed your matric?
Now, a matric our country is a university
and re-examination.
And I said, well, lady,
you must be very careful
because if the qualification
to speak to you is
the possession of a matric certificate
I might work hard and
pass my matric and be in
the same class as you are.
That was treason.
She said,
you will never be in my class
and banged the telephone.
(audience laughing)
How I wish she were here today.
(audience cheering and applauding loudly)
She would now discover
that I have achieved more
than pass my matric.
I hated oppression and when
I think about the past,
the type of things they did,
I feel angry.
You have a limited time to stay
on Earth.
You must try and use that
period for the pebbles
of transforming your country
into what you desire it to be.
- What can assure me, as a
human being, and a concerned
African American, that the
ANC will indeed have a fiscal,
solvent policy that will
continue the use of the resources
of South Africa in a meaningful way?
Or should I put it more succinctly?
Will your economy be based
on the Marxist system,
socialism, or capitalism, or both?
- I knew that was the
question you wanted to ask.
(audience laughing and applauding loudly)
I am happy that you have had
the courage to put it directly.
(audience laughing loudly)
We are not concerned with martyrs.
We are not concerned with labels.
We are practical men and women
whose solutions are dictated
by the actual conditions
existing in our country.
As somebody has said, we
do not care whether the cat
is black or white as long
as it can catch mice.
The first thing is to
be honest with yourself.
You can never have an impact on society
if you have not changed yourself.
And one of the most important weapons
in changing yourself is
to recognize that peace,
I mean people everywhere
in the world want peace.
But humility is one of the
most important qualities
which you must have
because if you are humble,
if you make people realize that
you are no threat for them
then people will embrace you.
They will listen to you.
- Was Muhammad Ali a hero of yours?
- Well, naturally.
As far as boxing is concerned
and what he has done,
he was my hero.
Just like Ruben here, this is my hero.
- What did you say to him
when he told you he loved you?
Well I was paralyzed
because it made my day.
(audience applauding)
- So what leaders of the
20th Century do you admire?
- Well, I've answered that question.
It's the not question of a leader,
it's a question of a human being.
Who does something to make an
ordinary individual to feel
I am a human being and I have a future
and I can go to bed feeling
strong and full of hope.
- And you have praised
Fidel Castro as a leader
of human rights and said that
Cuba was one of the countries
that's head and shoulders
above all other countries
in human rights despite
the fact that documents
at the United Nations and
elsewhere show that Cuba
is one of the worst.
I was just wondering, are
these your models of leaders
of human rights and if so,
would you want a Gaddafi
or an Arafat or a Castro to be a future
President of South Africa?
- One of the mistakes
which has some political analysts make
is to think that their enemies
should be our enemies.
(audience cheering and applauding loudly)
That
we can
and we will never do.
We have our own struggle
which we are conducting.
We are grateful to the world
for supporting our struggle.
But, nevertheless, we are
an independent organization
with its own policy.
And the attitude of every
country towards our attitude
towards any country is
determined by the attitude
of that country to our struggle.
(audience cheering and applauding loudly)
Yassir Arafat,
Colonel Gaddafi,
Fidel Castro,
support our struggle to the hilt.
(audience cheering and applauding loudly)
There is no reason
whatsoever why we should have
any hesitation about
hailing their commitment
to human rights as they are
being demanded in South Africa.
Our attitude is based
solely on the fact that they
fully support the anti-apartheid struggle.
They do not support it only in rhetoric,
they are placing resources
at our disposal for us
(audience applauding loudly)
to win this struggle.
That is the position.
- You'd also said to me
one evening, you said,
we made the brain dominate the blood.
- Our emotions said the
white minority is an enemy,
we must never talk to them.
But our brain said if you
don't talk to this man,
your country will go up in flames.
And,
for many years to come,
this country would be
engulfed in rivers of blood.
So we had to reconcile that
conflict and our talking
to the enemy was the
result of the domination
of the brain over emotions.
- And then you were convicted in 1964 for
conspiracy against the state and in your,
when you pleaded you said
that I am willing to die
for this cause.
This is a very tough thing to say.
- Yes,
I had to say that,
not from a spirit of bravado
but because I genuinely felt
that they were going to hang us.
And it is the desire of
every freedom fighter
to disappear under a cloud of glory
rather than that of shame.
It is the task of a freedom fighter
when you see that the
end of your days has come
to leave a tradition of
bravery, determination
to face even death for your principles.
And, I thought about it.
It was not because I was brave
but because one had a duty to perform
at that moment.
I have dedicated my life
to this struggle
of the African people.
I have fought
against white domination
and I have fought
against black domination.
I have cherished
the idea
of a democratic and free society
in which all persons
will live together
in harmony and with equal opportunities.
It is an idea
for which I hope
to live for
and to see realized.
But my Lord,
if it needs be.
It is an idea
for which I am prepared to die.
For anybody
who changes his principles,
depending on whom he is dealing,
that is not a man who can lead a nation.
(audience applauding and cheering loudly)
Apparently,
Mr. Koppel,
you have not listened to my argument.
If you have done so,
then you have not been
serious in examining it.
I have replied to one of our friends here
that I have refused to be
drawn into the differences
that exist between various
communities inside the USA.
You have not commented that
I am going to offend anybody
by refusing to involve myself
in the internal affairs
of the USA, of the USA.
(audience applauding loudly)
Why are you so keen that
I should involve myself
in the internal affairs of Cuba and Libya?
- No.
- I expect you to be consistent.
I don't know if I have paralyzed you.
- No, no, no, no, I.
(audience cheering and applauding loudly)
No, I.
I'm,
I'm afraid, Mr. Mandela, that
paralysis does not set in
quite that easily in my case.
The point.
(audience applauding loudly)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Michael B. asked me to.
So, if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave
it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I would also love to know
which of Nelson Mandela's
top 10 rules had the
biggest impact on you,
is going to change your life in some way.
Leave it in the comments and
I'll join the discussion.
And one last thing, my goal
with this channel is to get
to one million subscribers
so anything that you can do
to think of to share the
video, tell friends about it,
add it to the playlist, Tweet
about it, let people know,
I'd really, really, really appreciate it.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.
(quick sibilant music)